- How did y'all meet?
- We met in Chicago back in the late '80s.
- Yes.
- Actually the first time
I ever went to Second City,
Jane was understudying
for Bonnie Hunt.
- For Bonnie Hunt.
So I was on stage with
you and you ended up
- And then I ended up
understudying for Jane
a year and a half later.
I mean, it's such a weird small crazy.
- [Kelly] It is a small world.
- So we started singing together.
Well, first we did it for fun.
And then we started to do it for real.
Like we started going to events and galas
and we do a song.
And then when her show was canceled
and my show Glee was canceled,
at the same time, we said,
hey, we used to be a tour de force,
but now we're forced to tour.
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Expect more jokes.
- Come on.
- And you could expect
more jokes like that.
- And more hits like that.
Well, there,
there was a question going
around the Twitter universe.
I missed this, but everyone
was asking each other,
your last saved celebrity
picture is your therapist,
who is it?
And Jane tweeted this.
So your.
- You're exempt on it
and see the whole thing.
- Are you on a floating tube?
- I want to float is in a fancy dress.
Cause we just did a show in Palm Springs.
- And we were at Gerald Ford's old house,
which a friend of mine owns nights.
We call it Ford-knox.
(laughing)
- More jokes like this, guys.
- Oh yeah. More like that.
- Don't give it all away.